19e rencontre alternée des premiers
ministres québécois et français cette
fois ci c'est philippe couillard
emmanuelle weill est alternée parce que
une fois ci en france
l'autre fois ci au québec cette année
c'est au québec et on se trouve tout
juste à côté du château frontenac
très bientôt on va voir passer juste ici
manuel valls et philippe couillard pour
une marche chantée
beaucoup de médias français qui sont sur
place pour cette prise d'image parce que
c'est vraiment juste une prise d'image
patience et les manceaux les titres des
deux monstres accepte le souhaitent de
scotch évident installations métalliques
de toute végétation pousse entre limoux
comme d'ailleurs le séjour lui-même un
il est ultra rapide puisque on fait des
sauts de puces entre ottawa québec et
montréal et on va à saint pierre et
miquelon cet après midi donc c'est au
pas de course
on vient surtout finalement interviewé
ici le premier ministre ont des sujets
d'actualité nationale et hong kong
finalement assez peu le déplacement rend
lui-même
franchement il ya des gestes qui nous
font comprendre qu'ils s'entendent bien
qu'ils se sont compris sur certains
dossiers notamment celui de l'europe
quand vous parlez de justin trudeau je
pense que les français connaissent quand
vous palais du premier ministre
québécois monsieur couillard là je pense
que on a perdu tout le monde
la marche qu'elle marche celle qu'on
vient de faire la marche santé à pic
elle marche intel mars